Trascrizione: Martina Forasacco
Revisore: Chiara Polesinanti
Io non so, diciamo che non so
stare bene sul palco davanti a un pubblico
perché io sto in uno studiolo a casa mia,
a Pontedera, in provincia di Pisa,
e lavoro lì, lavoro da casa.
Sono uno di quei lavoratori
che Report in un famoso servizio
chiamerebbe quelli che stanno
in un loculo per 6-7 ore, immobili,
stregando il pubblico dei ragazzini.
Diciamo che è tutto un po’ diverso.
Io faccio lo streamer.
Lo streamer non è altro che una persona
che trasmette in diretta dei contenuti,
parla con il proprio pubblico,
guarda dei video insieme a loro
e soprattutto interagisce insieme a loro.
Ci sono molte chiacchiere, si parla magari
degli argomenti di attualità del giorno,
si parla degli argomenti caldi
che girano sull’Internet,
insomma si fa salotto,
ma salotto ovviamente
non a livello formale ma informale.
Diciamo che siamo tutti
sullo stesso livello.
E ho iniziato a farlo
qualche anno fa, due o tre anni fa.
L’ho fatto per gioco,
perché io vengo da YouTube.
Facevo video su YouTube
dove parlavo di cartoni animati e fumetti.
Il canale YouTube
mi andava abbastanza bene.
Poi a un certo punto non ho più...
non ci ho più campato, non riuscivo
a vivere con quello che mi piaceva di più.
Perché io volevo fare quello:
volevo creare dei video
e parlare a un folto pubblico
delle mie passioni,
perché ci credevo,
credevo che si potesse fare.
Purtroppo però YouTube è cambiato,
io sono cambiato perché sono cresciuto,
e sono arrivate le responsabilità:
la casa, la famiglia, la mia ragazza,
la mia compagna attuale,
e quindi io dovevo iniziare
a pagare le bollette,
a pagarmi un mutuo o un affitto.
E quindi ho provato con Twitch,
ho provato a interagire
con il mio pubblico in maniera diversa,
perché la cosa
che mi piaceva più di YouTube,
penso che tutti lo sapranno,
sono i commenti, cioè tutti voi
potete commentare e interagire
anche se la maggior parte delle volte
finisce tutto a schifio
e tutti si vogliono prendere
a coltellate nel petto.
A me quella cosa piaceva e non piaceva,
infatti ho moderato molto
i miei commenti su YouTube.
Twitch, appunto, con la possibilità
di commentare in diretta,
ha portato questa interazione
tra pubblico e streamer, e talent,
su un nuovo livello.
Anzi, secondo me ha annullato lo spazio
che c’era tra il pubblico e il talent.
Quello che non mi piaceva mai
della televisione
è il fatto che quando vedi
un Gerry Scotti, un Amadeus, un Bonolis
presentare uno spettacolo,
un programma tv,
c’è sempre quello
che diceva anche Pasolini,
c’è sempre quella forma
un po’ intimidatoria, no?
Lui comunque è quello
che ce l’ha fatta, è il vip.
Io sono quello che consuma il prodotto
che mi propone il vip.
Non è per tutti così, però si sente sempre
un po’ quel timore reverenziale.
Infatti molte persone quando vedono
un Bonolis in giro, subito foto, selfie,
“ti prego fammi un autografo”, eccetera.
A me questa cosa non è mai piaciuta,
perché a me è sempre piaciuto il pubblico.
Io sono drogato di persone: mi piace molto
interagire con loro, fare vacanze con loro
un po’ alla Bill Murray, infilarmi
ai loro compleanni o nelle loro feste.
Io per esempio ho fatto una storia:
“dopo andrò a ubriacarmi in spiaggia
con il pubblico che vuole
venire qui, pugliese”.
Insomma sono uno che vuole annullare
lo spazio che c’è tra talent e pubblico,
e probabilmente, modello John Lennon,
prima o poi qualcuno verrà e mi sparerà.
Non lo so.
Sono pronto anche a questo, è la mia droga
quindi fa anche in un certo senso male.
E Twitch, quando ho scoperto
questa interazione diretta --
c’è il pubblico che commenta continuamente
ogni cosa che fai, ogni cosa che dici --
mi ha colpito tantissimo, perché hai
veramente un’interazione totale.
E soprattutto, io streammo tutti i giorni,
è come un programma radiofonico,
io dalle 21:45 alle due di notte parlo,
gioco, interagisco con il mio pubblico,
tutti i giorni a parte il sabato,
con un programma o un palinsesto,
a volte guardo film,
a volte si parla del più e del meno,
a volte intervisto persone.
Sono venute persone
del mondo dello spettacolo,
del mondo della musica,
del mondo del fumetto,
le ho intervistate, chiacchieriamo.
È molto bello, è venuto Lundini,
ci siamo divertiti un sacco.
È venuto Igort, che è uno dei pesi massimi
del fumetto italiano.
Ed è molto bello perché si respira sempre
quell’aria di naturalezza, di casa,
perché streammo con un termosifone dietro,
una tenda dietro,
il gatto che mi scorre tra i piedi,
e la mia ragazza
che batte sulla tastiera
e rompe le palle a tutti quelli
che stanno ascoltando la stream.
Però è così, è quello il bello,
Twitch ha funzionato,
qui mi collego a quello che voglio dirvi,
ha funzionato perché non c’è più niente,
non c’è più quella barriera
tra talent e pubblico,
e questo è molto prezioso,
perché per una vita siamo stati abituati
a pensare diversamente.
E infatti con il Covid
cosa è successo, Twitch è esploso.
La piattaforma di streaming live Twitch
è diventata una delle maggiori piattaforme
che il pubblico dei più giovani utilizzava
per intrattenersi
in momenti di solitudine.
È stato detto anche in altri speech
che è aumentata
la depressione tra i giovani.
Questo è vero, e lo percepisco avendo
un’interazione diretta col mio pubblico,
ho parlato con diciottenni, diciannovenni,
ventenni che non sanno cosa fare,
sono incerti sul proprio futuro,
non riescono a dialogare
con la propria famiglia,
non riescono a trovare un amore,
non riescono a capire l’altro sesso,
o la propria sessualità.
E questo è molto importante,
perché con Twitch sono riusciti
a trovare compagnia,
a trovare un amico che c’è sempre,
alle 21:45 è sempre pronto ad ascoltarli,
a interagirci e soprattutto a fare battute
che sicuramente li intratterranno.
E questa cosa l’ho notata
soprattutto con una delle cose
di cui sono più orgoglioso.
Non mi piace vantarmi
di quello che faccio, però di questo sì.
Io durante il primo lockdown
ho fatto una live di beneficenza --
non so se lo sapete --
e questo crea anche molto schifo,
diciamo nell’uomo della strada,
su Twitch si possono donare dei soldi,
si possono donare dei soldi allo streamer.
C’è un tasto, lo clicchi,
si collega a Paypal,
e puoi donare un euro, due euro
addirittura ci sono persone che donano
100, 200, 1000 euro allo streamer.
Questa cosa fa subito rabbrividire tutti,
perché comunque sono soldi che regali
a una persona dell’Internet,
a uno sconosciuto.
Bene io ho deciso di prendere questa cosa
e farla diventare una forma di beneficenza
e abbiamo fatto una campagna
per raccogliere dei soldi
per poi donare all’ospedale
di Brescia e Bergamo dei respiratori,
quando c’era moria di respiratori.
E così abbiamo fatto,
abbiamo raccolto quasi 30.000 euro.
Siamo riusciti a raccogliere
30.000 euro che io ho donato,
poi ci sono le tasse di PayPal
che ho messo di tasca mia,
e siamo riusciti a regalare
questi respiratori,
e gli ospedali ci hanno ringraziato
per questa donazione,
un ospedale, non ricordo,
perché ovviamente nel casino non potevano
pensare a tutti i soldi che arrivavano,
perché sono arrivate per fortuna
anche donazioni fuori da Twitch.
Però è così, questo è molto importante.
Prima sentivo che si parlava di empatia,
quello che voglio dirvi è che Twitch
non è necessariamente il male.
Ultimamente sono uscite
delle polemiche su Twitch
perché ci sono effettivamente dei lati,
dei coni d’ombra su questa piattaforma,
ci sono persone che fanno
dei contenuti un po’ strani,
dei contenuti a volte non controllati,
dei contenuti borderline
che ovviamente possono effettivamente
andare a sconvolgere un po’ la mentalità,
soprattutto dei più piccoli.
Quindi io sono qui
più che altro per dirvi una cosa:
c’è una marea di ragazzi,
di diciottenni, di ventenni,
che hanno bisogno
di interfacciarsi con qualcuno
ma se si interfacciano con una persona
che li intrattiene non c’è niente di male.
Anche noi ci siamo intrattenuti
con i personaggi che vi citavo prima.
Ci sono persone che mentre vanno al lavoro
si ascoltano programmi radiofonici,
anche bestiali come la zanzara
dove si dice ogni tipo di atrocità.
Però è intrattenimento.
L’unica cosa che vi raccomando è
teneteli d’occhio.
Perché si inizia a brontolare
e si inizia a indignarci
solamente quando vengono fuori
le polemiche.
È molto importante, soprattutto in questo
periodo, controllare i vostri ragazzi.
Non star lì col fucile pronti ad aprire
la stanza mentre guardano lo streamer,
no, però dovete interessarvi sinceramente
di quello che vedono,
e con chi s’interfacciano.
Chi è questo talent?
Perché lo ascolti quattro ore al giorno?
Perché ti interessa quello che ha da dire?
Chi è questa persona?
A chi stai dando i soldi, soprattutto,
perché ci sono dei diciannovenni, ventenni
che si trovano il primo lavoretto
oppure ricevono una paghetta
e la spendono anche per queste cose qua.
Perché?
Perché effettivamente
gli abbiamo fatto compagnia.
Gli abbiamo fatto compagnia
e siamo riusciti a farci compagnia,
perché io dico la verità,
il periodo del Covid
anche per me non è stato facile.
Io ad agosto faccio 31 anni,
ma non mi sarei mai aspettato di stare
chiuso in casa per così tanto tempo.
E le live di Twitch, il mio lavoro
mi ha aiutato tantissimo
a stare tranquillo,
a rilassarmi, a divertirmi.
E anche quest’ultimo anno
dove ho ricevuto una brutta notizia,
il mio pubblico c’era, c’era sempre.
E questa cosa mi spinge tutti i giorni
ad andare in live alle 21:45
e incontrarli, parlarci,
continuare con questa filosofia,
ovvero quella di incontrarli sempre
e di abbracciarli
quando hanno bisogno di un sostegno
perché so che loro ci saranno.
Ovviamente i miei sono un po’ folli,
usano un tipo di ironia strana,
fanno dei commenti molto entranti.
Sono anche un po’ acidelli, però...
dentro di loro si nasconde un animo buono
ed è quello su cui bisogna lavorare
per cercare di capire questa generazione
che effettivamente ha qualcosa da dire,
anche su internet.
E quando sono su Internet
non è che stanno seguendo dei degenerati.
Semplicemente si stanno intrattenendo
con le nuove forme di intrattenimento
che stanno venendo fuori
in questi ultimi anni,
quindi cercate di capirle,
non rigettarle a priori
perché anche su Twitch
ci sono persone di talento,
persone che parlano di scienza,
persone che parlano di biologia,
ci sono grandi intrattenitori,
grandi comici,
persone che veramente arricchiscono
le persone quando parlano di qualcosa.
E poi c’è una famiglia tipo la mia,
che è pronta veramente a intrattenere
in ogni momento la loro vita.
Quindi questa è la mia raccomandazione:
siate empatici con le nuove generazioni
e soprattutto siate empatici
con le nuove forme di intrattenimento,
perché loro non vi rigettano affatto.
Grazie mille.